FOR ALL THE WRONG REASONS.
ALL THAT AND MORE COMING UP.
BUT IN A "NEW YORK TIMES" OP ED
CALLED FOR THE BREAKUP OF A
COMPANY HE BUILT WITH HIS BUDDY,
MARK ZUCKERBERG DURING THEIR
HARVARD DAYS.
HIS PEACE GOT HIM BOOKED FAR AND
WIDE ACROSS IN THE LANDSCAPE.
>> THIS IS A MONOPOLY, THE
MARKET IS FROZEN, THERE IS NO
COMPETITION AND THERE WAS AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE HAVE BEEN TOO MANY
SCANDALS AND PROBLEMS.
IT'S AT FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
COMMEND, BREAK OPEN THE COMPANY.
>> Laura: OKAY, WHO IS CHRIS
HUGHES?
THE HARVARD CLASSMATE OF
MARK ZUCKERBERG WHERE THEY
FOUNDED THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT,
FACEBOOK.
HE LEFT THE COMPANY OVER A
DECADE AGO WITH A SMALL VERY
LUCRATIVE STAKE VALUED AT
ROUGHLY $850 MILLION.
THAT'S ABOUT 1% OF THE COMPANY.
AFTER HE CASHED OUT, HE HAS
VOLUNTEERED BARACK OBAMA'S 2008
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, THEN HE
USED HIS NEWFOUND WEALTH TO BUY
THE NOTORIOUS LIBERAL "NEW
REPUBLIC" MAGAZINE, INSERTING
HIMSELF AS EDITOR.
TRY TO REHAB THAT, REVIVE THAT,
DIDN'T WORK.
HE SOLD IT OFF A COUPLE YEARS
LATER.
RECENTLY HE HAS BECOME A
PROPONENT OF UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME.
IT'S ONLY WHEN YOU KNOW ALL OF
THOSE LIBERAL BONA FIDES THAT HE
HAS THAT YOU START TO UNDERSTAND
THE REAL THINKING BEHIND HIS
CALL TO BREAK UP THE
SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT.
HIS MAIN GRIPE IS, "I'M
DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF AND EARLY
FACEBOOK TEAM FOR NOT THINKING
MORE ABOUT HOW THE NEWS FEED
ALGORITHM COULD CHANGE OUR
CULTURE, INFLUENCE ELECTIONS,
AND MY FAVORITE, EMPOWER
NATIONALIST LEADERS.
"THERE IT IS.
IF HE THOUGHT FACEBOOK WAS
AMPLIFYING THE RIGHT VOICES,
MEANING THE LEFT VOICES, THEN
THERE WOULDN'T BE THE NEED FOR
THIS CORRECTION.
LOOK, THERE ARE PLENTY OF ISSUES
WITH FACEBOOK.
PRIVACY, MONOPOLY, POWER,
ET CETERA, ALL OF WHICH WE'VE
DOCUMENTED ON THEIR SHOW.
BUT TO SUGGEST THAT THE MOVEMENT
AROUND THE GLOBE, IN EUROPE,
BEYOND, BREXIT, THE RISE OF
TRUMP'S ECONOMIC POLICY, THEY
ARE ONLY POPULAR BECAUSE OF
FACEBOOK, THAT'S JUST LUDICROUS.
COMPLETELY MISSING THE POINT.
AND AT THE BOTTOM, THIS IS
TYPICAL LEFTIST SNOBBERY.
WE DON'T LIKE YOUR IDEAS, SO
THEY CAN'T BE ORGANIC.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE WAY THEY
TREATED THE TEA PARTY BACK IN
2010, THEY CALLED IT ALL
ASTROTURF.
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED WITH
TRUMP'S ELECTION.
DISILLUSIONED ELITES WERE SO
SHOCKED THEY HAD TO CREATE
ANOTHER REASON FOR THEIR LOSS.
IN THE END, WELCOME OF THE
BREAKUP OF FACEBOOK MIGHT EVEN
BE A GOOD IDEA.
BUT THE REASONS THEY ARE PUTTING
FORTH THAT CONVINCING.
WITH THE EMERGENCE OF THESE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES AS THE
MAIN VEHICLE FOR DISSEMINATING
FREE THOUGHT, TO BREAK THEM UP